A very good reason, I want to share it.
USA Radio is in the shit right now.
It has been for 30 odd years I've been involved with it.
And I've tried at every level as an administrator to try and get some sort of semblance.
And I work for a professional organization and I see professionalism a whole different sort of way.
To be a good professional you have to be a very, very good amateur.
What we're doing here tonight is extremely amateur.
A hotbed of USA rugby was this club rugby.
And it was really, really strong in the 70s and 80s.
It was awesome.
The tournaments, there would be teams from the UK, from Australia, from everywhere.
They'd want to play the Chicago Lions or the Belmont Shore or Nova or whatever.
The Washington Rugby Club.
We don't get those tours anymore because of professionalism.
And it's kind of waning.
So how do we get our clubs strong?
Through recruiting, through staying vigilant.
Being very, very good amateurs turns you into a professional.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
We're not going to get any better.
Scott Lawrence is in our coaching group.
And the Eagles are improving slowly.
But I could have retired from this years ago.
But I'm still kind of going because I've got a lot of experience and I like to share it.
And I like to become that really amateur coach on a Tuesday night in the middle of wherever we are.
With new players, with the two older players.
And that's really the heart-beater of rugby as a tribute.
I'll leave it there.
But I think it's just how important it is to be a really proud of the club and your teammates.
And as you go into your fall season.
Jose will challenge me on schoolwork and things to improve upon.
As you guys start picking up on that.
Start picking up music before you get into it.
That's what's driving me right now.
That's why an old shit like this drives an hour out of the Shenandoah Valley to come into town.
Which I fucking love.